say goodbye to ex a sh a 12 yup along
bus and Grimes have already switched up
their babies names apparently the name
doesn't comply with California state
laws so the couple had to alter a but if
you thought the name transformed into
something a little more basic think
again the baby formerly known as ex ash
a 12 will now go by ex ash a 12 a 12
being in Roman numerals
Grimes confirmed the switch on Instagram
writing Roman numerals looks better to
be honest she also added that one - is
allowed to remain in her son's name
according to the California state
constitution names can only use the 26
alphabetical characters of the English
language also using numbers is not
allowed under those rules babies are
awesome they are pretty awesome they're
awesome yeah Elon and Grimes welcomed
their baby boy earlier this month the
Tesla founder went on Joe Rogan's
podcast to explain the meaning behind
their son's name my partner's the one
that actually mostly came up with the
name congratulations to her yeah she's
very named so I mean it's just ex letter
X and then the AE is like pronounced ash
yeah and then a 12 a 12 is my
contribution o ye 12 Archangel 12 the
precursor to the sr-71 coolest plane
ever so according to the proud father
the name is pronounced ex ash arc angel
12
however Grimes wrote on Twitter that
it's just ex like the letter X then a I
like how you said the letter a then I
regardless of how you pronounce the name
Grimes and Elan are parents to a little
cutie
[Music]